if you look at the elections in Israel
you have good news and bad news we'll
start with the good news the good news
is that Israelis usual actions to
replace the government which means that
they still stick to a very important
element in democracy the bad news is
that they have to go to elections almost
every year so and again and again so it
doesn't work
[Music]
you may first ask how this government
come to life because this is a weird
government the only glue for this
Coalition was the resentment to the
continuation of the rule of Angelina
Netanyahu the head of the liquid so it
worked for a year and few weeks and
that's it and this was also a miracle
foreign
[Music]
politician in Israel so we have a lot of
support we have support of about 40 45
percent of the population but it doesn't
get to the 50 51 and therefore we have
elections again and again in which he is
maybe the strongest person but he cannot
build the Coalition because the people
who resent him have a majority and the
only thing that brings them together is
Netanyahu and this is not enough to
sustain a government on the long run
[Music]
foreign
stability would be achieved either if
Netanyahu wins big or if Netanyahu
leaves the system because the right wing
in Israel can easily establish a
government without Netanyahu they have a
majority of more than 70 seats stability
can be achieved also if the rules of the
game will be changed if we will have
electoral reform or reform in the way
that we establish in the government
the public in Israel is now trained well
to go to elections every year every half
year actually if you look at the turnout
levels they are not so bad about 70
percent of the population go to vote
research that we made show that most of
the Israelis are optimistic about their
party ability to win so maybe this
explains why they go to vote again and
again while in other countries in which
they have elections every three four
years the election turnout is even lower
foreign
[Music]